dépité lassé fatigué Mathieu 28 ans a
rejoint le Gaek familial en 2018 et
s'occuper de 145 limousines 180 hectares
de céréales et autant de prairies c'est
déjà beaucoup de travail avec la météo
et le réchauffement du climat c'est
compliqué mais surtout il y a tout le
reste quand je me suis installé on dit
que c'était c'était dur mais c'est pas
dur au point au point actuel en fait on
a rien qui nous aide le peu qu'on faire
quelque chose on est embêté c'est que ce
soit des constructions ou même tout ce
qui est phyo le peu qu'on va dans un
champ les normes change tout le
temps Matthieu voit tout augmenter et se
complexifier autour de lui le prix de
ventere des animaux lui ne change
presque pas aujourd'hui entre MIDH et 2
il a rendez-vous avec le
vétérinaire on peut être un mois sans se
voir et des fois se voir trois fois dans
la semaine suivant le nombre de vélage
suivant les
pathologies sur le dossier médical ce
n'est pas simple non plus les
laboratoires arrêtent certains
médicaments non rentables les
résistances à certaines molécules se
multiplient et l'administration en
retire d'autres bon attends je vais le
sortir ce qu'il va faire une connerie il
va se faire mal une
patte
dehors le vétérinaire une centaine
d'euros pour aujourd'hui le coût de
l'énergie en hausse perpétuelle la
nourriture des animaux le matériel les
emprunts matthie en avant on permettait
d'autofinancer certaines choses là on
peut
plus c'est bah oui on est pr pr au coup
le jeune agriculteur travaille 10 à 12
he par jour du lundi au dimanche il ne
touche même pas le SMIC il ira
manifester